a convoy of semi trucks and tractors
have been making their way out of the
community of koots all morning down the
highway through the protest camp on the
highway here near milk river after 18
days protest organizers say the time had
come for this blockade to end
blockade supporters who had been camping
along the highway near milk river have
also been slowly packing up and heading
out protest organizers telling us this
was a difficult decision they still
support their cause but things changed
this week after police seized a cache of
weapons from several trailers and coutes
and made a series of arrests
after the events that came to light with
some of the
members
participants of this protest
having
firearms and protective equipment stored
in an other location in this community
our message has been one of peace
peaceful protests and to keep that
message strong we felt the best decision
was to move out there has certainly been
a strong effort made by many here to
keep this protest peaceful on monday as
decisions were being made about ending
the blockade we saw protesters shake
hands with police although there has
also been some hostility and tension as
well
as protesters leave the area commercial
trucks and other traffic are now
approaching the border once again
canadian border services agency
confirming this morning that services to
the coos border crossings has once again
been restored heather urex west global
news near milk river alberta